[Music]
no we got another black game oh gosh i
really was hoping you'd get a white game
so i could play d4 but we've got another
d4
oh my gosh
that's pretty funny we got three in a
row and another london system okay well
um
guess what of course i could now play
the kings in and i could showcase
a different line but let's see if let's
see if i can get a chance thank you for
the 300.
uh let's let's play the same line i'm
excited to see what this guy's gonna
play
uh just to hopefully we'll get a chance
to uh emphasize some of the concepts
that we just talked about so this is
pretty exciting stuff let's go d5 and
let's go c5 maybe he'll take
um we'll see what we'll see what he
plays
uh knight f3 okay
so knight f3
yeah knight f3 pres gives black more
more options than c3 does
but um i don't think we should reinvent
the wheel here let's let's still play
knight c6
and if he goes c3 this will be very
similar position to what we just had it
should be five okay
so bishop b5 is a little bit weird
just a little bit weird
because in the london general you play
c3 first so
there's a couple of options that we have
at our disposal
we can play bishop d7 that's the sort of
instinctual move and it leads to a very
solid position i think
um a lot of you guys should be seeing
queen a5 track and again it doesn't win
a bishop because of knight c3 but
at this level you sometimes do stuff not
because it wins material but because it
induces an undesirable move okay
now
what is the purpose of the london system
as a whole let's deconstruct it for a
second
the london revolves around the pawn on
d4 being a stronghold for white that
pawn on d4 is mega defended when white
plays c3 so
from a positional standpoint queen a5
check is a tremendously helpful move
why
who can put the pieces of the puzzle
together why would we want to induce
knight c3
well obviously we prevent him from
playing c3 and that pawn on d4 turns
from a weakness into a strength sorry
from a strength into a weakness
so let's play queen a5 trick in addition
the queen on a5 is very nicely placed i
mean there's nothing wrong with putting
the bishop under some pressure
uh and
we'll have to play precisely in response
to knight c3 so
right now we want to play actively we
don't want to go e6
because we're a little bit
underdeveloped and he'll go knight e5 so
how should we restrict the knight on f3
while also developing a piece i'm giving
basically giving it away but
i don't like knight e4
because i would prefer to emphasize the
development
so let's go vision g4 yeah this is a
very typical way of developing
and we're putting pressure on the knight
which is in turn defending the pawn of
d4k he takes we take that's nice
that leads to a very compact and a very
nice pawn structure i like the spawn
structure
okay so
we can take on d4
we don't necessarily
need to do that
we can also just play e6 and work on the
development of this bishop
on the other hand
one can make the case that e6 allows
them to take on c5 and relinquish the
pawn on d4
but on the other hand
is that really something we should be
worried about it gives away the whole
center
so when in doubt and by the way rook ba
be careful that bishop guards the square
when in doubt keep the tension let him
be the one to decide whether he wants to
take her knight that's always going to
be less of a headache than asking
yourself the same question
on the third hand no you can say that in
russian you can stay on the second hand
on the third hand etc
so here another question should we take
on f3 or should we drop the bishop back
now
to answer that question is it is
important to understand
that dropping the bishop back we should
ask ourselves is he realistically going
to play g4
and the answer to that question is no
that's a tremendously weakening move
there's no reason to assume
there's no reason to be afraid of a move
like this
so we definitely keep the tension here
he plays you for
and
in a blitz game i might have even
captured on g4 and considered the the
peace sacrifice
but um
in this particular instance i i don't
really want to do that i want to play
positionally let's drop the bishop back
to g6
why is g4 weakening will because he's
pushing a pawn out in front of his king
knight e5
this looks intimidating for us but it's
not uh it's a very surface level move
he's threatening the pawn on c6
uh all we need to do is defend that pawn
we gotta be careful about how we defend
it perhaps
some of you are spotting queen b6 but
that walks into the nasty move knight to
a4
we have queen a6 but here would be a
good time to apply the rule of peace
value
you you want to perform a task any given
task with a piece of least possible
value
which means rook c8
come back to what i said earlier does
that does this move look glamorous no
but there sometimes pieces got to do the
dirty work and there's nothing wrong
with that uh the rook is doing some
dirty work it's defending the pawn it's
not going to be doing it forever
eventually we're going to try to get rid
of this knight
but for the time being
we need to get our pieces developed and
the rook's going to have to suck it up
for a couple of moves h4
now this guy is this guy is very playing
actually very interesting style
so he wants to trap
our um
our bishop
okay so what's the general reaction to
this kind of move so h6 or h5 yeah h6 or
h5
either is fine
of course he could take on g6
but um that's not something to be
concerned about we play fg
and he continues to weaken his king side
so this is going to come back to bite
him i think in in a couple of moves
g5 now but the guy is very fearless i
have to hand it to him
now we should take for sure
for sure we should take just to open up
the h file
yeah this opens up a file to his king
so this is one of those games where it
seems like he might be in charge because
he's calling the shots so far but once
we end his initiative
we are it's going to be our turn okay
take on
g6
all right
now it begins to be our turn
so
we need to deconstruct this position and
understand what our priorities are
we probably are not going to castle
we're probably going to keep our king in
the center for the time being
now what do we want to achieve here
what's what's our goal how do we make
sure
that the h file works in our favor
well
we need to get rid of his bishop and to
get rid of his bishop
we can play in a very simple way we can
just play bishop b7
and eventually we can try to move our
knight from f6 and uh
initiate the trait of bishops so that
the h4 pawn loses its defender that
should be pretty sensible to everybody
it makes
okay and he actually just helps us do
that that is a
i think a mist i see what he's trying to
do he's trying to get his knight to f4
the guy is very very strong actually
he's he's stronger than his rating for
sure
um but on the other hand he allows us to
go 94. however on the third hand if we
calculate concretely that's where i have
to give my opponent some kudos 94 bishop
e7 king e7 knight f4
and guess what i mean that pawn on g6
being hanging with a fork
that queen comes into g4 i'm a little
bit concerned about that so i don't want
to do it
let's let's hold off on 94.
now
does that mean we abandon the general
idea no
and this is
sort of high-level thinking
um
a lot of the time
you would get frustrated in such a
situation and say well we can't that
means we can't move our knight but wait
a second
all we discovered is that
knight e4 is not a great move but
can we modify our plan we can't we can
go knight h5 i don't like this move from
the perspective that it it blocks the h
file but peace placement is temporary we
will meet we will deal with that night
uh it's far more important to accomplish
the
uh long-term priority of of opening the
hvac at knight g3
and you know we move the knight back
that's it
and the h4 pawn cannot be defended so
uh this difference between what's
temporary what's permanent is important
here um
sometimes you've got to break uh some
eggs to make you know you can't make an
omelet without breaking some eggs
and this is a good example of it okay
i'm going to speed up a little bit here
we're going to double the rooks we're
not going to relinquish control of the h
file the guy is playing incredibly well
though
um i have to say so i'm speeding up just
a little bit here we've won a pawn
we have pressure down the h file
and we have all of the positional
advantages here so black's got a great
position we just gotta play precisely to
carry this one home
if he plays queen d3
okay go c3 and finally he plays that
move
all right i think that's a little bit
too slow
can we pounce do we have an opportunity
to pounce on
uh
the initiative here can we can we
rev up the engines here
yeah we can try knight g4 but again i'm
sorry i keep i keep faking you guys out
um
let's start with the move queen b5 let's
start with this move attack the pawn and
try to like
get the queen into a position where it
can um can rejoin the game i'll show you
guys why i didn't like knight g4 after
the game he goes here
okay
let me think for a second
yeah we can do so many different things
here
the problem is if we go c4 he takes it
um
yeah queen b3 was incredibly strong
yeah we're going to go c4 anyway
we're going to go c4 anyway
and he's going to go a4 he's going to
find that move
no he's going to go there he's going to
trade rooks but that's
going completely astray because now in
the in the night end game we're up upon
um and we're going to start the queen
side pressure here let's go a5
yeah i'll explain i'll explain after
let's go b4 so what are we doing here we
are orchestrating the queen side
pressure
now let's bring our king into the center
of the board we can break through
further with e5 just trying to grab
space and break through in the center
now we can try to get our knight over to
a4 just like we would in the middle game
this is not going to be easy to win by
the way this might be uh
this is close to a draw
but we're going to try to uh
yeah that's a nice move yeah the guy is
he's very good now i'm going to make a
move here that looks really bad i'm
going to play b3
why am i doing this why am i closing
down the position because i'm trying to
fix the weakness on b2
um and
the way that i'm going to attack this so
he's actually helping me get the knight
to d3 and that was a decisive mistake
now he's busted because he cannot stop
my knight from getting to d3 and the
purpose of b3 is revealed we have fixed
his weakness and he won't be able to
defend it
all right
no at this point like these 1800s are
actually very very good this guy was
quite a bit underrated but he he's
definitely human and he just he just
played well
okay knight d3
this is not minus .5 i mean
you know i don't think so at least
boom
knight h1 defense
oh yeah that was a joke okay
yeah but king c1
yeah king c one knight d3 and then i win
the other pawn king c1 i win the other
pawn so
i win one of the pawns
sorry i was misleading
all right so where should we go here and
we can go back to a4 just to tie him
down to the c3 pawn
and now
we need to use basically the principle
of two weaknesses like the night itself
is not going to win you the game
uh we played to win the game
we need to get the king involved how do
we get the king involved we can play
king e6
but there is an even more elegant way to
get the king involved into the game
uh does anybody see it this is like a
little bit creative
we want to get the king to e5 right well
what's stopping us obviously it's the f4
pawn
that's why doubled pawns are so
phenomenal in the end game sometimes
if we didn't have a pawn on g7 this
would be unthinkable we would never
allow him to get a passer as it stands
we use one of the pawns as a battering
ram just to you know shake off his
defense
and now we go king e5 and the king has a
very direct passageway
uh to to paradise the moment he moves
his knight
um you know we don't want a blind lego
king e4 we spot the opportunity to take
on c3
sorry twisters is that important right
now
all right so what should we do
how should we where should we move the
knight
forkey where
yeah knight d1 for sure
and then we want to take another pawn on
e3
and that's a third one
and his position finally starts to
crumble
okay so where should we go we should go
to e4
okay so which how should we you know
what should we do how should we continue
there's a couple of options here
the key
you know the one thing you should
understand is like
there's this common piece of advice
don't hurry in the end game but that
doesn't mean you shouldn't push your
puns when you can you know you don't
want to take forever or he has his apon
he's going to push it
so don't you know don't dilly dally
forever c3
chris i i know don't worry guys i know
how much time i have trust me
everything is under perfect control
which pawn should we push now well we
can push b2 we can push d3 it doesn't
really matter
we push d3
no this isn't this isn't few like it's
trust me i it's not like it was a close
call okay so we should take the knight
of course don't go b2
b2 check and final sequence what's can
anybody spot the most accurate winning
idea here it's not c2
there is a there's an option here that
leads to checkmate almost immediately
does anybody see it
it's knocking d2 yeah it's knight c4 and
then c2 and
and b1 queen
so this is the most accurate knight c4
c2 and v1
yeah so c2 check
and um b1 wait check me okay
i was toying with you guys i mean i knew
i had five seconds but i it was also it
was also made
see one night well everything is made
thank you for another 200 bits
thank you sir
lots of good support today
you work our way back toward 5000 subs
it's good to see
no my accuracy i mean i mean both both
were good
okay
the end game the engine wasn't a fan of
either side during much of the end game
well
fair enough so we had another london now
in the last game you guys will remember
that
c3 happened followed by knight d2 that
is the more
uh that is considered to be the more
accurate move order
and um after knight f3 knight c6
bishop b5 is i guess this is a move i i
don't think it's the best
um
and i think there's a couple of i i
honestly don't understand the c and d
pushes by black in the opening
well it's i mean one of the most basic
sort of opening principles is that you
need to control the center with your
pawns
are you familiar with that uh with that
rule
because that's that's sort of the basic
opening rule that's the whole premise
behind moving your pawns out into the
center of the board
um
if you're familiar with that then these
moves should make sense we're basically
grabbing space in the center
to facilitate
yeah so that's all that that we're doing
um
i mean
it's hard for me to go
to that level but if you're familiar
with that that's basically what we're
doing here okay
so knight f3 knight c6 bishop b5 queen
a5 track knight c3 so this is the
concept of provoking
uh we are provoking knight c3 in order
to soften up the d4 pawn and at this
level
these kinds of moves become very
commonplace you're not you know
blunders are less frequent and so to win
a lot of these games
you need to celebrate small victories
you need to provoke
relatively small weaknesses and you have
to start becoming comfortable with these
various positional considerations such
as oh i'm getting his knight to c3
um and a layman could look at this
position and say well what the heck's
wrong with bringing the knight out to
its natural square but if you are
familiar with the london you know that
the pawn belongs on c3 not the knight
all right
bishop b5 is not bad i would say it's a
little bit inaccurate
all right so bishop g4
yeah i mean i understand stockfish um
stockfish might say bishop g4 yeah that
also seems very sensible
um
i don't like to use the engine in these
positions because i'm going instead for
a conceptual illustration
this is not really like jabba london
why don't i like knight e4 i'm not sure
where
so bishop g4 okay so bishop c6 bc bishop
c6 was unnecessary i think he should
have probably castled
oh 94 here oh sorry 94 in this position
i got it yeah so the reason i didn't
like 94 ladies and gentlemen is because
because of castling
and okay
black wins a piece right i take c3
bc3 queen takes b5 so
i'm just done right
what am i missing here what are we
missing
not rook b1
but white has an intermediate move
which intermediate move does white have
of course he takes with check
bc bc
now i understand that some of you are
looking at this and saying well black's
up upon like why didn't you go for this
but that's exactly the thing
at this level you cannot just
look at the position and say ah we're up
upon so we have a good position you have
to look at the other
you have to contextualize this
and
what other considerations are well
clearly black is hugely lacking in
development we literally don't have a
single piece developed
white has his entire army ready to
rumble
this gets super nasty really fast he's
got the b file
uh anybody should be able to see that
white has huge compensation here so
it you know doing all of this for for
the sake of winning a pawn is just not
something i consider to be worth it
and there's a lot of these layers you
know of consideration 94 looks very
logical but concretely i didn't think it
was that good
bishop g4 i always like to prioritize
the development
all right
well
chess is hard
castles e6 this is normal h3 bishop h5
um
yeah so we could have taken on f3 here
and essentially softened up the d4 pawn
uh yes well you know as emanuel alaska
said i spent the first half of my chest
career learning roles in the second half
unlearning them to paraphrase and yes
you could put it that way at lower
levels it's all about mastery of
fundamental principles short calculation
tactical pattern recognition and at
higher levels all of those things are
absolutely true they still decide games
but you can see these
very subtle
considerations start to creep in such as
when do you violate the rules when do
you find exceptions to the rules
um you know you see these subtle subtle
considerations of provoking certain
moves and
weak pawns
one analogy that i've i heard this
analogy from somebody i thought it was
very nifty
uh to demonstrate how the uh makeup of
most chess games changes um
you know from level to level you can
think of like a war the first time
anybody's made a war on knowledge you
can think of a war
and
none of what i'm about to say is aimed
at you know condescending to the to
lower ratings or any i'm not trying to
say your games are less meaningful but
it's just a way of understanding how
things work i think
uh so at a beginner level you're
you know you're basically
throwing grenades at each other and
you're just
you know
you're going after the opposing army
with knives and trying to stab
the enemy forces
and then the higher rated you get
the more
sort of
localized the fighting becomes at
13 1400 level
you know you might be launching
long-distance weapons at the other army
without actually engaging in
hand-to-hand combat and then at 18 1900
level
um
you know you might start engaging in
cyber warfare there's no guns that are
actually fired everything happens
through computer channels and then at
master level
uh you're
you know you're engaging in thought
you're trying to control the
thought of uh your enemies or you're
launching
bio weapons or something you know you're
the the fighting gets more sophisticated
and the less noticeable
um
sorry to spend so much time on this
analogy but that's just one way of
looking at it i think
yeah diplomacy diplomacy is used
um
so the
sort of
the playing field becomes more narrow
and it's less oh the game's decided by a
blunder by some bomb that falls it's
it's much more
sort of subtle specific
okay
bishop h5 g4
espionage awesomeness thank you for the
prime
why didn't i sacrifice on g4 because
we get two pieces for the piece which is
not two pawns for the piece which is
nice
what i didn't like
is that we have no other pieces on the
king side and the queen is uh you know
on the other side of the board white can
go key to a very typical move reinforce
the knight the queen is capable now of
moving away i didn't see a good way to
continue the kingside attack yes the
king is very weak i think we've got
compensation
but i i kind of started not liking it
okay
so
that's the bottom line
the center bonds are like the un exactly
good i like that you guys have
taken this analogy for so bishop g6 95
rook c8
and i'm gonna be completely honest i
missed h4 i i just didn't
uh it didn't register that he did he had
this idea and i want to give my opponent
a lot of credit for
uh you know playing so boldly he's
pushing pawns on the side of the board
where he has
his king
uh and you know
that's uh that's pretty admirable i
think that
he started only going wrong here i think
g5 was unnecessary
um thank you i appreciate it g well
thank you i think g5 was unnecessary he
went a little bit too far he opened the
h file for me
what should he have done i think he
should have taken
and then i don't i don't think i was
lost
um
wait andres i was like i don't think i
was lost
necessarily in this game but i guess i'm
wrong
um
i mean if you're checking with an engine
i've i'm no match for that
so uh we would have gone king f7 here
and black is
i think black is better in this position
he's got a ton of weaknesses we have c4
but um
you know the game goes on i think g5 is
a little bit going overboard so take
stakes
takes whoa jeff jam with a 10 and the
fireworks continue
thank you
wowza
4 am hype
i didn't get the sense that i was worse
either but again the engine knows best
that you guys are a lot more attached to
checking the engine evolve than i am to
be honest
and that's the reason i don't check the
engine evo because
um i might have been worse in a specific
moment another 10. damn
damn that is crazy the guy is
on fire all right
well before i was rudely interrupted uh
by loads of gifted subs
now basically
okay so let me make this clear
using an engine to
detect mistakes is great but i would
caution you not to get too worked up
about these evaluations oh i was you
know plus 0.3
or i was a little bit worse a little
better
uh
you should use the engine to look at big
mistakes
rather than try to like overanalyze and
say oh you know i made a small
inaccuracy here because at that point
you can obsess forever over tiny
inaccuracies
um so bishop e7
92 knight h5
the thing is um
also the engine might mislead you
and
you know it might reduce it might crater
your confidence when in reality you
played a very nice game thank you jim
jim gifting to marius margulis
um he's creeping up on 35 500 gifted
that's crazy
it might create her your confidence and
say oh you know i made all these
mistakes i all these inaccuracies when
you might have played an excellent game
so
just you know put things in proper
context here
all right so bishop b7 king e7
uh and again why didn't i play knight e4
because after bishop b7 king e7 knight
f4 that pawn on g6 is hanging
we can't play rook h4 we get forked
uh and if we we try to defend this spawn
then he brings his queen into the game
and all of a sudden all these pawns are
hanging
c takes the instead of knight h5 i was
thinking yeah we could have taken but
what does this really give us
angel thank you for the prime i don't
know what this gives us
uh i'm not sure
uh how this changes the makeup of the
position or who this benefits five
gifted from jam jam he doesn't stop
holy smokes
thank you
yeah so anyways knight g3 we dropped the
knight back to f6
and now uh and i think knight g3 was a
mistake
i think knight g3 was a mistake what
should white have done here well he
should have recognized that one of my
ideas is to move the nightback curious
chimpanzee with a five
whoa
we've got tons of hype here at 4am
all right
so what should white have done here how
does white prepare
for
the opening of the h file and think
about okay we want to defend the h-bond
potentially so what should we do
this is a yeah king g2 is excellent
knight f6 and okay knight f6 is bad
because he still has knight f4
but even if he didn't he would be able
to play rook h1 so you're always sort of
asking yourself not only what is my
opponent's threat but how does my
opponent want to reposition his pieces
the more questions like that you ask
yourself
the greater the possibility that you'll
be able to find moves like king g2 the
knight g3 knight f6
king g2 he plays now but it's a little
bit too late we win the pawn
we get the pressure down the h file
we're in great shape
now he played c3 and here
at first i was going to play knight g4
and this looks incredibly good right
because it i mean it looks like we're
threatening rook h2 but you know what
the problem is here the problem is that
the queen is so far away from the action
and the rook and the knight kind of bite
off more than they can chew
so i was worried here that he would go
queen to f3 bringing his queen into the
defense and preparing to get his rook
involved with rook h1
and if we give this check automatically
then after king g1 look at what happens
the knight and the rook have no pawn
support if only we had a pawn on f5 or
an h5 we would have been in tremendous
shape
but that knight is now uh
dead mean i mean we have to go back to
h4
it takes we lose the knight
so
that's why i dialed it back and decided
to go queen b5 first there was a very
specific idea
the idea is that if he goes b3 which i
was hoping for
now we go knight g4
queen f3 and if you compare the two
positions the queen here is on b5 on the
other line it was on a5
well does that matter
who can tell me why this does matter
yeah well think about where the queen
one good way of thinking about this
where can the queen go
uh it holds f1 but it can go to d3
that's the bottom line it can go to d3
it can centralize itself attack c3 and
participate very directly in the attack
so
you really have to
you know take this apart where can the
queen go where it couldn't go when it
was on a5
and hopefully that makes sense
so that was the idea i was trying to uh
make a move that preliminarily prepares
for knight for but to my opponent's
credit queen b3 is very strong
and this creates a nasty little
situation
because
if i well if i don't do anything then he
simply takes on b5 and takes on c5
that's a free pawn
i decided to go c4 ultimately
but after the queen trade i think that
had he played the correct move
white would have probably not been worse
the correct move to find the correct
move you must realize the rook on h4 is
very misplaced it was very well placed
earlier with the queens on the board but
now that there's no attack
it's totally irrelevant and white
strikes with a4
that's a pretty obvious move i was
surprised he missed it
it's natural
and apparently he's slightly better now
how should black respond to this i was
gonna go before and sacrifice a pawn to
keep the rook and the file closed and i
think this is double edged i mean either
side can still win
uh we've got a very nice pawn here he's
got weaknesses we've got weaknesses too
uh he can go knight e2 knight f4 and
stuff so
white is definitely not worse here
i didn't see a good move in this
position honestly and i could have maybe
dropped my queen back to a6
um
yeah well what about a6 well we don't
want to play a6
because look at what happens he's got
the full a file he can give us a check
he can even go rook a5 and pick this
pawn off
and uh he totally dominates over the
queen side that's kind of a worst case
scenario
queen b6 oh yeah that's a
and that's a great example of trading on
your own terms
right you drop the queen back
and that was the move that i was looking
for you trade on your own terms if he
takes on c5
then i guess we can take on c5 and this
check is not scary we just cover it with
the knight and we're still up a pawn
that's a very deep move that i should
have seen
i should have seen this move oh queen c7
wow so it's saying just give that pawn
up and go aim for the king so maybe that
gave the biggest advantage but
that queen b6 makes sense that's a
findable move
that's definitely a findable move um
it just didn't occur to me for some
reason
it didn't i only thought about taking
the queen or or forcing the queen trait
and once he goes rook h1 this leads to a
very nasty night end game where not only
are we up a pawn
but we have this massive queen side pawn
pressure which results in the ultimate
creation of weaknesses equals a3 we go
b3
um and and our idea now is to bring the
knight over to a4
and tie him down to this to the b2 pawn
and then and then bring our king over
essentially to the other side of the
board uh and start attacking his pawns
on the other side he's going to get
overextended here i think this is
probably winning already d takes e5
exacerbates the situation because uh the
knight now jumps into d3 and he can't
defend both of these pawns at once
at 49d3 thank you harris 3h for the two
months
and this game is over and after knight
d3 i mean we made a nice move g5
fg king e5
and then get the king off fix the
weakness just means it doesn't mean
fixes and it was broken
but it is you know
you know it it
means just to stabilize it like not to
let it move
um
like fix it as in make it immobile
cement it yeah yeah basically
all right can't you play d4 well d4 is
worse because that allows him to create
a protected past pawn
g5 by contrast
doesn't let him do that because we still
have this pawn thank you fan for the 12
months thanks
you have to be creative yeah
you absolutely do and
thanks for the one year
yeah so after that we go king e5 knight
c3 we dropped the knight back well we
know we actually win the pawn and now we
have this
massive pawn army
which we convert very easily c3 d3
takes takes
p2
knight c4 even more accurate than going
c2 although that's also possible
generally in such positions thank you
defender of time for the year we uh
we want to give away
as many pawns as it takes and promote
the one that you know that advances the
fastest
yeah and this is just checkmate thank
you lether for the prime oh my god
this is crazy
i'm loving this all right uh just one
second here
yeah the london is um no that's tea
you know the london is is incredibly
popular
these days but
it's um
yeah it's
it's good for some players it's very
good for some players thank you for the
200 bits
fan yeah it was a cool new one i mean
kangas six was totally winning as well
but uh you know people up by eric rosen
uh you know it's become very very
popular and it's a good system
i i'm i'm very cautious of recommending
it to people because it can become kind
of almost an addiction like you just
play
the same line over and over again and
stuff like that
so you got to be careful
do you have any old soviet chess books
on you i do
i actually brought one home to to
charlotte
i brought a uh so in
in e they eat eat ease in
in the 70s 60s 70s the soviet chess
federation released a yearbook sort of a
yearly
uh compilation of articles and you know
opening articles and you know tournament
reports
and it was like super high qualities
hardcover
like
incredible there were articles by all
all these gm's that were commissioned to
to write uh that kind of stuff so
uh i brought one of those books with me
uh to use to use in my lessons and stuff
but i i think i'm gonna i'm gonna be
back tomorrow guys and we're gonna do
more speed running so
[Music]